[Music]
liberty so what am i gonna do about
grace
what's the big deal why don't you could
i get a scotch more gravy that's a
little dry
you don't like danny i mean just tell
her it's a bad idea i don't tell people
who to marry
okay you always tell me what you think
of the men i date i'm talking about
marriage not rudy the jewish cowboy you
met on the internet
shalom my lonesome prairie dog
[Applause]
look she's your best friend will you
have to tell her what you think be
honest
i can't before my brother married ginny
he asked me what i honestly thought of
her
i told him she's morose and controlling
and icy
well i got married anyway now she hates
me and my brother and i don't talk
i couldn't handle losing grace like that
hmm
you know i'm gonna call rudy again
oh god i'm sorry but more importantly
that's terrible about you and your
brother
it's awful it's no no no do you have any
mineral water sulfites
so when are you moving in well i'm going
to be away on business for a while
what business business i have business
and clients and work related
business how is the work-related client
business these days
what is this why do you have to be so
mean
because you love it and i love you and
and you love
jail and you have a home here when you
get back
you see you can be a very great guy when
you want to be well
i got to be nicer to you yes you do
because you are a good friend
yes i am i know it's got to be rough on
you will don't i'm trapped in a man's
body like that
[Music]
hi hey
what are you watching pop-up video turns
out
fiona apple doesn't particularly like
apples
apple brown betty was invented by a guy
named darren and get this
bobby darin's dog was named fiona what
are the answers
i said yes what
i said yes oh my god
oh my god
wow let's have a look at that ring oh
it's beautiful when is the stone being
put in
i knew you were gonna say that wow
you know i'm i'm thirsty
what what what i'm happy for you
lying lying man talking grace stop it i
am
happy for you i i want you to have a
great life together
you do
oh thank god i was so worried coming
over here
so i have your blessing then
yes
i love you love you okay
i've got to go tell my family grace
don't
i have to will they're paying no i mean
don't marry danny what
honey i got to be honest this this guy
is not enough for you
i mean you're you're passionate and
you're you're creative and beautiful and
perfect and this
guy i mean you should be with someone
more somebody else
i mean he's not funny he he doesn't know
what your favorite flower is he's
passive-aggressive the man
high-fives you after sex
you're so afraid you're never gonna get
married you can't even see how wrong he
is for you i mean
think about it if you really believed he
was the one
would you be asking me for my blessing
go to hell will
you